I give this try to cook a little bit
more right so you don't get salmonella
and then we're all good
welcome to my kitchen as a tasty
producer I felt like I just needed to
put out two of my best friends to a
little bit of a cooking challenge would
you all say that you're good cooks no I
knew this moment was coming because it's
always trying to make us cook but I'm
willing to take on challenge today the
challenge before you ladies you watch a
tasty recipe one time through but you
don't have any instructions beyond that
and at the end I'm going to judge who
did the best job so you see it once and
then you do it right but there's a twist
it is very difficult to make it is
actually something that takes a lot of
people years of practice to master will
you help us like are you here to like oh
I'm just wondering why you thought this
was the best thing to start us with it's
an omelet how could you screw up an
omelet we're about to find out so this
is the video pay attention because I'm
actually only gonna play it one - okay
okay clear my my gotta get mentally
prepared I'm getting rid of any useless
information in my brain right now okay
three greediest I already see two on the
screen so let's go all right let's watch
out
Oh No
oh there's no cheese no okay I can do
that I'm not sure joking common omelet
an omelet without cheese okay well this
is a French omelet they just do things a
little bit differently how do you feel
about it I think I can do that I was
trying to like take note on the texture
and like how when they're done so I
think that was my biggest challenge I'm
getting like scrambled eggs vibe they'll
hold and then it rolls so I'm kind of
scared that's the technique that's why I
chose this recipe all right okay I think
we're ready to I'll see you ladies in a
given omelet
oh I think what she did there okay
wardrobe first wardrobe first oh yeah
specialty ring this might be the most
challenging part of this video Maddog
doesn't work oh yeah mine either it's
not turning on is it plugging I'm
pushing the on button Wow no egg shell
yay I'm trying so hard not to get
eggshells in here that did not happen
oh I didn't even watch how much soap any
time I've cooked with Vaughn he's all
about the salt you have to get salt in
everything
actually there's like two grains of a
sole and then beat the egg right I don't
know I'm not at liberty to discuss I
can't remember a fifth temperature it's
supposed to be medium low or medium high
I don't even know if I have it on medium
low or medium high or none of the above
I have it on medium okay oh shoot I
don't want to melt my butter yet because
I have to let my stove get back down to
medium low my philosophy with cooking is
just like put it on the highest heat
possible get it done cooking's annoying
like can y'all please put the knives
down you're acting like it's like a wand
tell me what to do oh wow oh I press a
lot of butter butter a good better
never hurt anyone well actually ahead I
have hired a lot of people I'm just
gonna put it in I don't know
I'm being reckless right now oh wait I
think I'm supposed to move different Oh
sharp things on the pans no no please
don't do that I'm having memory loss
right now oh look at who's helping okay
Oh like this oh oh it said move it
around while it's in the pan I kind of
want to eat this butter I love butter
besides I wish I was kidding
I wish I was like bad at this Wow that's
disgusting
this is so hard this requires
coordination that I don't have to poop
like that maybe I can't I just feel like
going up higher is going to burn the egg
I've been fitted up one more oh Oh Oh
sounds yeah I have not done it maybe
it's what you're supposed to do all
along oh my god I don't want to fail and
see some chunk starting to form
I mean chunk is probably one of the
worst words of the human language no
baby or get chunky baby chunky chocolate
chip cookie dough one of my favorite
Instagram accounts is chunky monkey it's
a bit and that's also a ice cream flavor
I'm not even flippable I think I'm just
gonna do it I have nothing to lose
am I gonna burn myself right now huh oh
oh okay it's a little wait Livan you got
to eat then I got a head nod sure
Ashley that's nothing Sakura nice okay I
think I'm gonna flip man oh boy
this is the party thought it was gonna
be the best happening Oh scallions are
hard to cut I'm just gonna use my plate
why are you making me really nervous
oh you're holding baby then tell me help
me so I don't hurt myself just want you
to give this because I think I just may
have created a masterpiece of commies
galleon Bay you both successfully made
it off at least so that's good yeah that
giving me like a little crunch oh he
took a large bite that was dangerous I
mean not terrible all I've ever wanted
to hear from you you did overcook it my
mouth is like a desert right now it's
not too much salt I would even have put
more salt that you did you didn't do a
bad job of making an omelet I did a bad
job breaking a french oh okay
I've never had an omelet before I don't
really eat nice before just a moment do
you like yeah okay essence yes right off
the bat you do have a better texture I
will say it's a little springier you
started off with a really good technique
if you were a little bit more patient me
a patient I think you could have really
succeeded we shouldn't have any of this
browning on the bottom but let's taste
it let's see are you speeding for
anything else in these eggs this is why
I ordered delivery you know what it is
what if you would have kept scrambling
it would have been good and then like
flipped it while they were still creamy
but then you just
I like it it's a firm Ashley this is a
little creamier just cuz you took it off
sooner and you added one butter which
honestly makes it I don't really know
what I did to be honest you know it's
fine but for the purposes of this video
it's not that cut my entire soul like I
said a for effort you started off on the
right track but I think that today's
winner has to be Ashley
I never thought I would see today yeah
Wow yes I'm happy I'm also not
competitive at all what I think we did
work together we did
if one positive thing came out of this
experience is that Ashley Ashley likes
it and if you like those eggs you're
gonna really love it I always still
taste it yeah and I hate it
[Music]